so now you get invited to red carpets
and things yes and literally on red
carpets is this you this is the time the
time 100 most influential people in the
world ever you're one of them
how did this happen I don't recall that
I was
yeah they I was one of the hundred most
influential people even though no one
hears heard of me
and I was on the red carpet and you know
when you're doing interviews and the
person sees somebody more important
behind you which is always for me it's
like being in a party and there's a
hotter girl behind you and they're just
like like they want you to drop dead so
I saw the reporter do that and all the
reports are going crazy in this Kim and
Kanye and just standing there just like
owning it just like being like short and
important
and I just couldn't I like think falling
is the funniest thing so I just I just
took a dive in front of them
[Laughter]
[Applause]
ographers miss the moment when Kanye
broke a smile no that did not happen
follow-up picture where I loved it like
you're struggling for help in the next
one you could have been a drowning child
he was just walking it was yeah no he
did not crack a smile at any point and
then I talked to them after I saw them
and I said to Kim I was like oh sorry
you know when you were like in front of
a celebrity I just become such a flake I
was just saying things I didn't mean I'm
like you and your sister this inspiring
and like anda and Kanye like was smiling
at me like but like as if you programmed
a robot to smile like he was just like
yeah and but there's no way that either
them had any idea who I am
why you're on the floor but look I look
like a Pantene ad like my I look pretty
good down a boob could have fallen out
that really this should be your red
carpet pose always just crawl the red
carpet everybody
see if you can spot the the reason why I
was a little bit disappointed by my
first appearance in a national paper
okay this is it I don't believe this
Fleetwood we're breastfeeding is always
welcome
[Music]